the jurogan experience
this is uh
an odd idea but i think what it's doing
is it's
forcing us to adapt and evolve our
ability to detect to detect [ __ ]
and it's doing it almost like
an immune system response
like what what we're reacting to and
what we're recognizing from all this
stuff is like oh we didn't know what
this was
and this has
resulted in this riot
whatever you want to call the capitol
hill attack
and now we're looking at
more censorship on social media
we're looking at uh you know like
them trying to batten down the hatches
and figure out how to handle
something like queuing on or the people
that were allegedly
promoting these ideas a lot of them that
are banned from social media the stuff
that you highlighted in your show we we
have to figure out what's true and
what's not true and so there's been some
sort of draconian measures that have
been um
suggested you know like
hiring some sort of a team that goes
over
social media and makes sure that
everything is according to what they
deem to be correct or incorrect
which obviously is
subject to biases and we're we're very
aware that that's going on today that
there's a lot of that going on today
whether the necessarily a truth doesn't
like the hunter biden laptop story is a
great example of that right like uh the
social media platforms
they censored news from the new york
post one of the oldest newspapers in
america
on the hunter biden laptop story because
they decided that somehow or another it
was propaganda or somehow or another it
was not good to get that information but
it was news it was real news
it was a real story
and they decided it was too close to the
election this could hurt biden we don't
want trump to win so you're dealing with
biases this is not just like simply
here's information that we know to be
true or here's information that we know
to be a lie we're going to stop that
from getting through no they knew it to
be true but they decided to stop it
because it wasn't convenient or it
didn't fit the narrative they were
trying to promote right it's very
it's and how do you find a neutral
arbiter right the truth right um if if
you are going to entrust someone with
that responsibility and i think that
that's it it's just an incredibly
slippery slope incredibly slippery and
and what these big tech companies have
have
uh suggested is that well maybe we don't
use humans maybe we use algae eyes right
you know to to moderate everything and
you know the algorithms had had that
in many ways had bolstered something
like q because they're they're basically
uh sociopathic when it comes to just
trying to drive attention as much as
possible so now they can kind of invert
those algorithms and and punish those
who um talk about uh that kind of
content and often times even if even if
their goal was just to predict prevent i
don't know conversation around um q and
on because they consider it to be
problematic what else gets swept up what
else gets swept up with that
um
i mean i saw i saw a lot of people who
were reporting on q and on maybe coming
from the uh the side of critiquing it
their videos were being wiped out um you
know people who were documenting january
the 6th their content was being wiped
out people who were critical of q and on
they had websites that were um sort of
on the other side that was being wiped
out as well and and that's because of
course it's a it's sort of this blunt
force that that
an algorithm wields so people even
people that were analyzing the movement
from a critical standpoint people who
are looking like how ridiculous this is
look at this they had their channels
wiped out as well
yes so any content on cue and not they
just want to erase it from the internet
essentially that seemed to be the the
initial response yeah it's it's so
strange it'll move together in sync i
mean i i think that if i did not have
you know hbo in my sales with this
project it wouldn't have seen the light
of day really like if you try to put it
on youtube you think
oh yeah yeah i mean when we even when we
so when we first released the series um
you know there was there was there were
some articles floating around like oh
maybe this is going to make it things
worse
um if i typed in q into the storm into
youtube it wouldn't auto populate at a
certain point it started out auto
populating and then that went away
so
um
yeah i i i wouldn't feel confident at
all that um you know if we didn't have a
gorilla in our corner
uh that um
that this story that revealed ultimately
who was behind q anon
uh
would have been seen
would have been able to find an audience
um and then shout out to hbo shout out
to hbo i mean they really have my backs
they've been amazing for decades you
know you really think about it i mean
they're the people that when bill
maher's show politically incorrect got
pulled off of what was it on abc i
forget yeah i'm not sure network
television um they immediately took it
brought it over turn it into real time
and made it even better you know it's
uncensored now and
and it's in my opinion real time with
bill maher is probably one of the very
best
social commentary
shows and and comedy shows that like
really doesn't pull any punches on any
network ever you want to hear something
[ __ ] crazy so
yes just yesterday i was talking with
someone who's helping distribute the
film and
i said well what about amazon you know
are we gonna be able to put it out on
amazon internationally and they said
well
as of the last year they have stopped
taking documentaries
all documentaries what you cannot
publish a documentary
on their platform and the reason was
because that i was told is because
you know there was there was all this
conspiracy flat earth stuff and they
were they were getting blow back that
eventually they said we don't want to
have to decide what we publish and what
we don't what's real and what's not
we're just not going to publish anything
and the example they gave me
that they couldn't get published was the
cove i don't know if you saw that
the dolphin document
documentary you know it won an oscar
yeah and i just uh just to check it you
know i looked it up and sure enough the
cove wasn't available on on amazon so
you know those who said that there
wouldn't be a slow creep of censorship
you know kind of starting with things
that i think everybody agrees should be
you know they wouldn't like to be in
society you know things like the daily
stormer maybe a lot of people don't want
8-chan you know it's a there's a
progression yeah you know until you end
up it seems like something like
you know that the cove can't find an
audience on a major platform
and i don't want to conflate
government
censorship of the corporate censorship
too much however in a lot of ways it
does feel like the government has passed
the buck to these corporations to do
what they
legally can't
which i think is the same thing we saw
the government do with privacy right
like they wouldn't have been able to get
all of this data from us directly but if
you give it to a facebook or a twitter
it's very easy for the government to
then go and get access to that
information
so i think what we saw happen with the
fourth amendment we're now seeing happen
with the first amendment where they can
say well look we couldn't restrict
conversation around certain topics we
couldn't directly
decide what's true or what's not we're
going to put that in the hands of these
companies and of course these companies
have
intimate relationships with um with many
members of of the government you know
there's a revolving door there so
i i
when people want to talk about what
limiting what we can say online or
limiting um disinformation to other
things i i think that it's almost the
wrong place to start i think we have to
go back to the privacy issues
and i actually think if we had not let
privacy be eroded online we wouldn't be
having this debate
you know because if
if these gigantic companies hadn't
collected thousands of data points on us
you know didn't know
our fears our desires
if they hadn't built these psychometric
profiles they wouldn't have been able to
manipulate us use these algorithms to
drive us into echo chambers which have
really created these disparate realities
and now these disparate realities can't
agree necessarily on a set of facts
sometimes
you're considered
you know sometimes people will be
ostracized for even to talking to
somebody from the quote unquote other
side right
um
and and so now there's this conversation
about what should be allowed to be said
online uh and i think that that's simply
a byproduct of of
you know our privacy having been eroded
so
you know if i was to do anything about
these issues i would start by restoring
rights i would go back and say all right
well how do we get you know how do we
get
ownership and privacy rights
online when it comes to our our personal
data let's start there before we we
start you know going after the speech
itself
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify